all right the topic is dinner we can't
stop talking about food in studio right
yeah right it's 6
48. starving
at first it was thai food and now you
guys got me on pizza now yeah well you
can't go wrong with
either of them you can never did you
hear that that was my stomach
just you could hear it on my microphone
just so you know we're almost done here
all right guys uh
high for the day today 59 degrees 57 is
our normal for this time of year
it's dinner time we're only human 40
degrees overnight for the low
record was 68 degrees set back in 2007.
can you believe it was almost 70 degrees
back in 2007 on this date 51 in
centennials right now let me promise you
we would always switch up our
neighborhoods here for you every
newscast so let's start off there in the
northwest part of valley sky canyon same
for you this is up there in providence
48 in summerlin 51 in alente downtown
double fives for you 59 sunrise mountain
just shy of 60 degrees at the six
o'clock
hour wow that's still nice and mild 54
for green valley
henderson 51 and rhodes ranch mountains
edge
southern highlands all at 54 degrees 49
currently in seven hills and anthem
outside the valley here you go prop 57
over the hump 54 boulder city
and let's see let's start off with sandy
valley this time you're at 55 right now
not bad at all armagosa valley also
at 55 degrees here's how it looks across
the lower 48 states so nice and cool
here milder in phoenix
chilly the far north you go up there in
boise the
wasatch 33 in salt lake also on those
high 30s for kc
oklahoma city 41 50 in nashville d.c
coming in at 42 degrees
here's our doppler network now trying to
find any type of
precip any type of showers with those
clouds we just do that wasn't going to
happen not even in the mountains so
clouds will thicken a little more from
this narrow band here in the next
hour or so i'd say and then we have some
showers way off in the sierras here that
will
just stay there then in fact they'll
turn on change over the snow the sierras
will swallow up most of that moisture we
call that
uh rain the rain shadow effect what we
will get are more clouds
and a little bit of wind for tomorrow
more of the clouds will be those systems
that were
that would be off for the pacific
they're one after the other
uh what they'll do is they'll stay to
the north and unfortunately we're going
to get like we said
clouds and also occasional wind so
tomorrow for your golfing forecast not
bad
all right we'll call it good rather than
excellent because we'll get those winds
to kick up just a little bit
62 our high for tomorrow we'll have
those north breezes
stronger locally stronger down the
colorado river valley
light winds at first and then some
breezes later on in the afternoon in
fact here's your day planner
41 tomorrow morning 57 by lunchtime like
we said 62 degrees plenty of sunshine
for tomorrow
here are neighborhoods for tomorrow in
the afternoon centennial hills you'll be
at 60.
sky canyon included aliante 61 summerlin
59
mountains edge at 61 spring valley 61
also desert
shores in north las vegas 64 green
valley henderson 60 even
saint rose park we enabled them in the
high 50s 59 for prompt 60 for boulder
city
69 for laughlin and death valley at 70
degrees now here's your extended
forecast
temperatures will be mild look at that
in the 60s even overnight lows not too
bad
we'll see occasional clouds mixed in
with some sunshine all the way through
friday
cooling off for the weekend breezy winds
and look at that back down the mid 50s
for sunday and then
rapidly warming back up to near 60 again
with mixed sunshine again
on monday uh this time monday not bad at
all that's your most second forecast i'm
gonna get a bite to eat i'm starving all
right
yamasushi all the way